Хто бодай один раз був у Берліні, знає
німецька столиця має одну серйозну проблему - безпритульні
Майже половина усіх берлінських бомжів родом зі Східної Європи
люди, які у пошуках кращого життя
приїхали до Німеччини
Польські соціальні працівники Дарек і Войтек
хочуть допомогти своїм землякам повернутися на батьківщину
Привіт, я Дарек.
Привіт, а мене звати Дзядек
Я працюю в організації "Барка" разом зі своїм колегою Войтеком
А, я чув про "Барку", але я не повернуся назад до Польщі. Там у мене нікого немає
Але ти маєш нас
Під "нами" Войтек має на увазі
соціальні установи благодійного фонду
"Барка" у Польщі
Дарек знає, в якій ситуації знаходяться безпритульні
Він знає їхню долю з власного досвіду
Коли мене забрали з вулиці, я, мабуть,
доживав свої останні дні
вже не міг навіть ходити, мав обморожені ноги
такі рани на ногах утворилися через морозні ночі
А спав я у спальному рюкзаку на якійсь будові
Завдяки працівникам "Барки" Дарек знову налагодив контакт
зі своєю донькою після 14 років поневірянь
Дареку та Войтеку вже вдалося повернути
13 безпритульних поляків на батьківщину
Дехто повернувся до своїх родин, інші розпочали терапію в соціальних установах "Барки"
Дарек і Войтек переконані,
що лише в Польщі їхні земляки
зможуть зробити новий старт у житті
Однак самі безпритульні бачать це інакше
як, приміром, 43-річний Станіслав, що вже рік бомжує в Берліні
У Польщі немає по-справжньому підтримки для людей з вулиці
для алкоголіків чи наркозалежних
У Німеччині інакше, в разі чого тобі допоможуть
Утім, державної програми допомоги таким, як Станіслав
у Німеччині немає
Підтримку у ФРН отримують лише ті, хто тривалий час пропрацював тут
Усе інше - це ініціативи благодійних організацій
Для Дарека та Войтека
кожен повернений на батьківщину польський безпритульний - це успіх
Але на берлінських вулицях цього не дуже помітно
Тисячі східних європейців
тут і досі живуть на вулиці.